[muzică]
Am un ditai animalul. Bă, băieți, dita
mai animalul îl am aici. Dita mai
animalul.
Hai să încercăm.
Deci, nu aveți idee cât de mare e.
Vai de capul meu!
Mamă, mamă, mamă, mamă!
Haide, mă, vino aici la mine. Hai, hai,
hai. Nu, nu, nu, nu, nu, nu, nu, nu, nu,
nu, nu, nu, nu, nu, nu, nu, nu, nu, nu.
Hai, hai. Așa, așa. Bravo.
Haide.
Mamă, mamă, mamă, mamă, mamă. Ăsta are
11 kg ca popa, bă, băieți. 11 kg ca
popa. Cârli micuț,
cârlig de 10.
de 10. Scuze, nu e de 10. Cârligul este
de șase.
Mamă, mamă. Nu știu dacă voi vedeți pe
cameră așa ceva, dar e fenomenal. Deci
fenomenal. N aveți idee.
Vai de capul meu!
Dragi pescari, suntem în Delta Dunării.
La sfârșit de octombrie cu bilele Delta
Activ a intrat acest superb și de
Dunăre. Uitați vă la el cum arată. Încă
nu l am cântărit. O să văd câte
kilograme are după o perioadă în care nu
s a prins pește în Delta Dunării. Iată
că a venit timpul acestor recorduri
minunate.
Ia să vedem.
11 800. Hai să zicem că 800 are capul de
minciog. Deci 11 kg. Da. Brațulina,
aproape de luna noiembrie. Suntem la
sfârșit de octombrie. Cu ce credeți?
Vă salut, dragi pescari. Suntem din nou
pe apă. Suntem pe brațul Sulina la
sfârșitul lunii octombrie, început de
noiembrie. Sâmbătă o să fie data de 1 și
o s o prind și pe o să pescuiesc și
sâmbătă și duminică. Este o partidă de
patru zile pe care o fac, de cinci zile.
De fapt, eu am venit de miercuri, am
venit de ieri, am sondat câteva locuri,
am nădit vreo patru locuri pentru că
sunt și cu alți prieteni. Este și Mihai
Manea cu noi. Eu am venit înainte, am
sondat, am căutat peștele, am am făcut
nădire și ați văzut un pic mai devreme
am prins acel crap minunat de 11 kg. Vă
spun sincer, când am plecat de acasă, am
plecat cu gândul că este posibil să fie
prima lampă de anul acesta pe care o fac
în Delta Dunării. De ce? Pentru că
probabil unii dintre voi știți deja în
Delta Dunării deja de patru săptămâni nu
se prinde pește. Ba a crescut, ba a
scăzut, a fost tulbure mult timp și s au
prins foarte puțini pești, poate chiar
să zic așa 1 2 colo. Deci nu a fost o
frecvență în crapi și mai și mai puțin
crapi mari. Da. Deci Crabman nu s au
prins. Silvan a fost și el săptămâna
trecută și a stat patru zile și în patru
zile a reușit să scoată doar doi pești
de 8 kg în condițiile în care Silvani
este un pescar foarte bun. A fost tot
peina, câteva locuri mai sus de mine.
Bun,
iertați mă, mă mă suna Mihai. Probabil a
a avut și el un drill, ceva. Ce am făcut
în partida asta? Cei care mă văd cum
pescuiesc acuma îmi spun că sunt un pic
nebun pentru că pescuiesc contra
curentului. Eu acum sunt pe sunt pe
sulina pe partea stângă și după cum
vedeți în partea în spatele meu este
crișan. Da, deci apa curge așa, iar eu
pescuiesc contra curentului.
Și o să vă spun în comentarii de ce
pescuiesc contra curentului. O să vreau
să mi scrieți voi cei care știți sau
care presupuneți de ce fac lucrul
acesta, să mi scrieți în comentarii de
ce o fac. Sun curios să văd dacă dacă
aveți idee și o să scrie în comentarii
de ce amit contra curentului. Bun. Ce am
făcut ieri? Am venit și am nădit locul
acesta. Am o ciată în dreapta mea, am o
ciată în stânga și în față este un
perete în apă, este un Epi. Așa este
denumirea lui sau cel puțin așa o știu
eu de la pescar. N am căutat niciodată
să văd dacă este corect sau nu. Este un
în apă. Este practic un perete care este
făcut artificial de cei care s au ocupat
de brațe ca să nu se colmateze. Ok. Și
eu ce fac? Pescuiesc la baza acelui
epic. De acolo am luat și peștitele de
11 kg. Am mai avut încă doi. Încă doi,
de fapt am avut un ciortan pe care am
reușit să l scot și am mai avut încă
trei rateuri din partea stângă, dar n au
fost prești mari. Deci n o să zic că au
fost crești mari. Am fost tot așa
3 kg până la 4 kg. Și am mai scos unul
de 700 de g și bineînțeles peștele de 11
kg.
Acum eu am început partida cu lansetele
din stânga pe care m am dus pe apa mai
adâncă. Le am început cu
bile Delta Activ de 20 mm solubile cu
plumb pierdut, iar pe cele din partea
dreaptă am început cu momitoare.
Momitoare cu pelete de 10 și cârlig de
10 pentru că efectiv nu știam ce se
întâmplă. Nu știam dacă având în vedere
că nu se prinde pește în Delta Dunării,
i am zis: "Mă, el este super mofturos și
poate î păcălesc cu momitoare." Ok. Am
pescuit cu momitoare în partea dreaptă.
Ce i drept, nu m am dus pe adâncime cu
momitoare. Am dat undeva pe 6 m, pe 7 m
și am luat câțiva carași. Am avut și o
trăsătură mai violentă, dar a intrat în
niciodată. Acelea probabil era un
ciortan. Am luat carasă, am luat
plătică, am luat roșioară și acum pentru
că am văzut că a intrat peștele acela
mai mare și crapii pe care i am prins de
v am spus tot de pe adâncime au venit pe
bilă simplă, fără momitor și acum am
schimbat, am pus
le am pus și pe cele din partea dreaptă
pe bile de 24 semisolubile Delta Active.
Ăă, în momentul de față când eu
povestesc despre lucrul acesta, Delta
Activ nu este lansat pe piață. Probabil
va fi lansat în următoarele săptămâni,
așa că o să puteți să le achiziționați
de pe site ul nostru gdafishing.ro.
Bun, cam asta este strategia. Asta am
încercat să fac. Am nădit. Am nădit
aseară când am ajuns din nou, am nădit.
Am praștia la mine. Am nădit cu praștia
la un interval de o oră, o oră și
jumătate am nădit cu bile semisolubile
ca să stea mai mult pe substrat. Ieri am
nădit și cu solubile, am nădit și cu
Delta Secret biletari. Am făcut așa o
nădire mai mare. Ok, o să stau astăzi
până se până se întonecă pe locul
acesta. Să vedem dacă mai reușesc să
scot încă ceva. Oricum, eu sunt foarte
foarte foarte fericit, vă spun sincer,
pentru că am reușit să scot un pește de
11 kg și câțiva ciortani, având în
vedere că eu am venit cu impresia, cu
ideea că, bă, este posibil să fie prima
lampă și na, pentru că mie mi a ieșit,
am dat de pește și am oarecum am și
riscat practicând pescuitul ăsta în
curent contra curentului, dar mi a dat
roade. Așa că ce o să facem până la
final? O să mai facem câteva clipuri.
Poate vă arăt și o montură, dar oricum
montura deja o știți, monturile le știți
pentru că le am mai prezentat în
clipurile de pe YouTube. Dacă nu mă
înșel, este în clipul de pe Sulina în
care se numește pescuit pe brațul Sulina
de la Zet. Da? Deci oricum puteți să
intrați acolo să vedeți monturile pe
care eu le folosesc și poate vă mai dau
câteva drilluri, poate vă mai spun
câteva tips and tric să vedem ce adaptez
pe pe parcursul partidei în cazul în
care n o să mai i am trăsături și na,
poate o să vă ajute pe unii dintre voi
ceea ce eu fac aici. Stați cu mine până
la final.
Hai să l vedem și pe ăsta dacă și ăsta
este de 11 băieți. Și a dat drumul
peștele pe deltă.
Ăsta pare mai micuț, dar
o
ăsta e la 4 5 kg.
Delta Delta Activ,
de data asta semisolubilă.
Hai!
Deci trăgea, trăgea. Am avut un drill
atât de, cum să vă zic, de puternic și
trăgea atât de tare încât am crezut că
este tot un pește mare.
Este un pește de,
hai să zic, un 3,5,
dar
avem activitate.
Ăsta a venit de pe larg. A venit pe o
bilă de 24 semisolubilă. Am băgat
n am mai am scos oarecum o lansetă de
acolo de unde vă ziceam că dau în
peretele acela și am dat o în stânga pe
larg să vedem care i treaba și a venit
acest frumos frumos crap. O să îl lansez
din nou acolo să vedem dacă cumva este
un banc acolo și dacă mai prind dacă mai
scot ceva de acolo. Dacă mai scot ceva
de acolo o să mai scot o lansetă și o s
o bag tot acolo în partea aia. Dragi
pescari, prima zi de pescuit este
aproape gata. Mai stau un pic, strâns
culele și o iau spre cazare pentru că o
să înceapă să se întunece. A fost o zi,
din punctul meu de vedere, reușită. Am
avut vedeta de 11 kg și încă doi pești
scoși scoși la poze și câteva rateuri.
Așa că pentru luna aug pentru luna
octombrie la sfârșit, începând de
noiembrie este foarte bine. Mai ales
pentru faptul că în deltă nu prea se
prinde pește, cum unii dintre voi știți
deja. Mâine o să vin în același loc.
Acum, după ce plec, când plec, după ce
mă dezancorez, o să fac din o nădire, o
să nădesc baza acelui perete pe de care
v am povestit. După care mâine dimineață
o să vin și o să montez gulele și tot
aici o să pescuiesc. Așa că stați cu
mine până la final să vedem poate mai
reușim să scoatem ceva din locul acesta.
Dacă mâine nu o să am nicio trăsătură,
mâine fiind vineri, sâmbătă o să schimb
locul, o să încep să caut O să încerc să
caut loc cu peștii în altă parte. Dar
vedem, vedem ce se întâmplă mâine. Dacă
și mâine am trăsături, dacă și mâine am
capturi, o să rămân tot aici până până
la final. Vă salut. Înainte să plec,
înainte să strâng sculele, am mai avut o
trăsătură, un run. Efectiv s a lăsat pe
ea foarte bine și a intrat într o cioată
pentru că
nu
și nici nu l mai simt.
Mai am trei lansete băgate. Poate, cine
știe, poate e ora în care mai trage un
pic. Ia să vedem dacă l las așa. Se mai
simte peștele.
Nu, nu se mai simte.
Cred că plumbul pierdut nu s a eliberat,
nu și a făcut treaba sistemul și s a
agățat în ceva.
Altfel nu mi explic pentru că sunat din
fața mea ar trebui să fie curată.
Ia să vedem dacă i mai dau fir.
Nu,
nu mai simt peștele. S a eliberat. Asta
e. Bună dimineața, dragi pescari. Suntem
în a doua zi de pescuit. Am ajuns
dimineață,
fix când se lumina.
Am lansat
lansetele. M am poziționat un pic altfel
față de ieri. M am pus cumva cu spatele
bărcii mai pe larg. Vă arăt imediat.
Deci cumva m am m am pus mai pe larg.
Da. Două lansete le dau în partea
dreaptă contra curentului. De fapt trei.
Una este mai pe larg, cea din mijloc și
cea din stânga am zis o pun și normal
cum se pescuiește în josul curentului
când curge apa în partea stângă a pe
prag. Acolo nu am nădit. Acolo este
efectiv la intercepție. Să vedem dacă
intră ceva pe pe zona respectivă. Iar
aici în partea dreaptă când am ajuns
dimineață am nădit. Am nădit și aseară
când am plecat. Și acum așteptăm să
vedem să vedem ce o să iasă.
Pescuiesc în continuare cu cârlige de
șase. Pe două lansete am cârlige de șase
cu bilet de 20 și pe două lansete
cârlige de 4 cu bile de 24. Toate bilele
sunt solubile. Delta activ solubil. N am
băgat semi solubil momentan. O să vedem
puțin mai încolo. Fiind început de
partidă, vreau să se activeze repede și
în cazul în care peștii sunt pe aici să
s o ia mai repede decât decât o
semisolubilă. Deși și semisolubila după
ce se activează e foarte bună de de
trăsătură. Cam atât pentru dimineața
asta. Așteptăm să să
vedem ce se întâmplă. Ieri eu m am pus
undeva pe la ora 9:00 pe locul de
pescuit și am început să am trăsături de
pești crapi la 3 kg 2,5.
Am renunțat la momitoare în acum. Deși
dacă n o să am nicio trăsătură, două o
să le bag pe omitoare să văd care i
treaba.
În același timp am și niște colegi
pescari care s au pus lângă mine. Ia
stați să vă arăt.
Deci mai am aici pescari
care
le am explicat unde dau eu și că dau
contra curentului. Au înțeles și dau și
ei cumva în partea dreaptă. Nu, nu mă
încurcă.
Să vedem dacă au ei trăsături. Înseamnă
că peștele este pe zonă. Dacă am eu
trăsături, înseamnă că peștele este pe
zonă. Dacă ei o să aibă trăsături, pot
să fac și eu același lucru pe care îl
fac ei, adică să lanțez la distanțele
lor. Cumva merg pe aceeași linie,
aceeași strategie ca pe baltă.
Na, vedem ce se întâmplă. Și a venit
primul pește din a doua zi de pescuit.
Nu am reușit să dau drumul la cameră,
dar vi l arăt acum.
Arată bine. A venit din pe la Zed din
partea stângă de v am spus eu că am pus
o la intercepție. De acolo a venit și o
să lăsez din nou acolo să vedem dacă mai
sunt acolo. Dacă mai sunt acolo o să fac
și nădire și o să mă mai mut o lăsat în
partea stângă pentru că în partea
dreaptă momentan n am avut nicio
trăsătură. Deja am lansetele în apă de o
oră și 20 de minute. Și ăsta este primul
pește. Hai să vedem ce mai vine.
O trăsătură pe lanseta a doua din
dreapta spre stânga.
Tot așa ciupitură,
iar am observat așa din trăsătorile o
ciupitură și după care intră pe run.
Aice a lăsat o.
Da, a lăsat o. Asta e. N avem ce face.
Este deja ora 10:00. Până acum am prins
doar un singur pește.
Am mai vorbit și cu ceilalți prieteni
care sunt.
Cred că vreo șase bărci așa pe lângă noi
pescari care ne cunoaștem și
nimeni n a prins niciun pește. De fapt
nu. Sile a scos un crap și am mai avut o
trăsătură de pește mare.
A intrat pe ran, l a ținut. L a ținut
vreo două minute, nu putea să l ridice,
lua fir, se ducea, se ducea, lua fir,
dar nu putea să l țină și până la urmă i
tăia firul. Na, asta e.
Dragi pescari, nu mi vine să cred.
Suntem la sfârșitul lunii octombrie și
este foarte, foarte cald afară. După cum
vedeți, m am îmbrăcat în tricou, în
pantalon scurt și am fost nevoit să pun
și Bim meniniu pentru că efectiv mă
topește soarele. Iar în ceea ce privește
pescuitul, cred că această încălzire
bruscă, ceva a făcut să se schimbe în
comportamentul crapului. Încă nu mi dau
seama ce. Deja
sunt, cred că este ora 12:00.
Este ora 12:20 și am avut o singură
trăsătură, un singur pește. Ce am vorbit
și cu ceilalți pescari și în dreapta mea
și în stânga mea nu s a prins pește. Tot
așa 1 doi rătăciți. Asta înseamnă că
peștele a că înseamnă că și a și a
modificat comportamentul într un fel și
încă nu mi dau seama cum. Stau să mă
gândesc să mi văd despre ce este vorba.
Oricum astăzi toată ziua o să stau aici
pe locul acesta. sau o să neesc în
continuare. Cu praștia îi dau bile la
fiecare oră sau o oră și jumătate. Și
dacă n o să am niciun rezultat de mâine
o să mă regrupezc să văd ce aș putea să
fac în perioada asta când s a încălzit
foarte foarte tare. Ok, este ora 1:30.
În continuare este cald. Nu am mai prins
niciun pește notabil. Am luat un ciortan
la 1 kg, dar n am mai apucat să dau
drumul la cameră.
Încă nu am găsit un răspuns. Încă nu
știu ce se întâmplă cu peștele. Eu tot
sper că va reveni pe patul de nadă sau
că este aici, dar nu se hrănește și la
un moment dat va începe să se hrănească.
Eu i am dat bile continuu. Chiar acum am
terminat de de înedit cu bilet de 20 și
de 24
semisolubile.
Așteptăm să vedem ce se întâmplă. Încă
nu am un răspuns. M am gândit că ce ar,
unde ar putea să fie peștele în momentul
ăsta când apa s a încălzit. De fapt,
când afară s a încălzit brut și automat
începe să se încălzească un pic și apa
la suprafață, că ar putea să fie pe apă
mică. Dar
nu prea aș vrea să risc să plec din
locul ăsta care este înădit, pentru că v
am zis mai devreme, au mai fost câțiva
pescari pe aici. E posibil să rămân fără
el, având în vedere că este deja în
nădit. Cel puțin astăzi o să stau până
la sfârșit pe acest loc, iar dacă nu
reușesc să scot nimic notabil de mâine
încep să schimb strategia, încep să caut
pe apă mică. Oricum suntem mai multe
bărci care nici ei nu prind și posibil
dintre ei să înceapă să se ducă pe apă
mică, dar nu știu. O să vedem acum după
după masă. Băieții au plecat la masă.
După masă o să vorbesc cu ei să vedem ce
putem face.
Deci, am schimbat locul și acum am venit
să sondez.
Mihai este
de vreo 30 de minute aici și deja a avut
patru drilluri. Aici este o apă mai
mică.
Suntem tot pe solina. Suntem pe digul de
piatră
și
aici aproape de mal apare, hai să zicem
că 20 30 de m de la mal spre noi.
Apa are în jur de 3 m
și aici o să aici o să căutăm o zonă. Eu
am mai pescuit pe zona asta aici și am
niște pietre în apă pe care vreau să le
găsesc. Le am salvate și pe sonar
și să vedem dacă țin și pește. Da.
Așa. Deci acum am ajuns fix pe fix pe
prag, adică fix unde începe coborârea.
Și de aici până la mal încerc să vă arăt
un pic. Este apă de 4 m
între 4 și 3 m, bineînțeles. Și la mal
deja se se ridică așa. Și acuma hai să
vedem.
Ce loc ne alegem? [muzică]
[muzică]
>> [muzică]
>> Deci, dragi pescari, cam așa vin
rezultatele, căutând peștele și având
informații, vorbind cu mulți pesari.
Așa ajungem să găsim zone bune și să
găsim să prindem pește pentru că de unul
singur, de foarte multe ori de de unul
singur este greu să găsești zonele unde
se hrănește, cum este acuma. Ieri s a
prins cât de cât pește binișor, astăzi
nu se mai prinde pește și atunci trebuie
să facem ceva. Trebuie să căutăm. Uite,
Mihai a găsit o zonă aici pe apă de 3 m.
Plinde pești la 3 kg, la 2 kg, la 4 kg.
Ă, dar nimic mai mare, într adevăr. Nu
știu. Să vedem. Dacă intră ceva mai
mare, ne va contacta și ne va spune și
atunci ne mutăm și noi pe apă mai mică.
Sile este și el mai în față pe apă de 12
m. În continuare este pe 12 m și
pescuiește acolo. Adică, cumva încercăm
să
să acoperim toate zonele. Da. Și zona de
adâncime și zonă pentru că dacă începe
să mănânce undeva pe adâncime este clar
că va mânca și în alte zone, tot pe
adâncime. Dacă mănâncă pe apă mică, este
clar că va mânca și în alte zone pe apă
mică. Și atunci căutăm apă mică. Da.
Bun. Plec, mă duc pe un loc de pescuit
recomandat de Costeluș și după care
revin să vedem de acolo dacă avem ceva
dacă avem ceva activitate.
[muzică]
Dragi pescari, am riscat. În a doua
parte a zilei am venit pe apă mică. Nu
am avut succes, din păcate. Am scos, Am
avut un run, nu am reușit să l scot și a
a scos cârdigul din gură și am mai scos
un ciortan la 1 kg.
Mai este puțin și se întunecă. O să
strâng la setele și o să plec. Și mâine
este o nouă zi. Am o informație de la
Andrei care a rămas pe locul pe care el
l a nădit pe apa adâncă pe 12 m, care a
luat unul de 10 kg și unul de vreo 6 kg.
Deci cumva cred că riscul pe care eu mi
l am asumat [râsete] a fost o greșeală.
Dar ăsta este pescuitul. Dacă rămâneam
acolo era posibil să
am și eu ceva pești mai mari, dar na,
asta este pescuitul, îl căutăm. Am
descoperit un alt loc care sunt sigur că
în viitor îmi va oferi ceva capturi.
Bun, gata, mă apuc de strâns. Ne vedem
mâine. Mâine mai am o zi de pescuit.
Mâine este sâmbătă, o zi întreagă de
pescuit și duminică o jumătate de zi de
pescuit. Așa că stați cu mine până la
final să vedem dacă reușim să mai
scoatem ceva frumos la poze. Bună
dimineața, dragi pescari! A treia zi de
pescuit. Din nou este soare. Astăzi va
fi iarăși cald, la fel ca ieri. Am
schimbat locul. Nu am mai mers pe locul
pe care l am nădit nouă zi, două zile la
rând. M am dus pe el astăzi. Am sondat
un pic cu sonarul, am văzut mulți
fitofaci și ceva mi a zis să mut locul.
Am venit pe un alt loc. că am căutat cu
sonarul, am căutat apă mai adâncă, am
găsit o apă de 16 m. Practic, sunt la
trecerea dintre 14 m 16 m în șenal. Da,
aici toată zona din fața mea în șenal
apare 16 m și, bineînțeles urcă treptat
până lângă barcă, aproape la 2 m, 2,5 m.
Sunt ancorat în stuf.
Pescuiesc cu bile de 24, două bile de 24
pe două lansete și bilet de 20 pe
celelalte lansete Delta Activ. Am făcut
o nădire, am ieșit în larg, am nădit cu
barca. De fapt, înainte să mă pun să mă
ancorez, am nădit am nădit din barcă. Am
dat bilet doar solubile de data asta ca
să se activeze foarte repede.
Și cam asta este. Băieții noștri, Mihai
nu a avut nicio trăsătură. Sile a avut
un pește de 7 kg. Acum vreo 40 de minute
a luat un pește de 7 kg. Și cam astea
sunt informațiile pe care le am
momentan. Eu o să rămân aici, nici nu
știu, undeva până la ora 12:00. Poate o
să rămân aici, o să dau aici. Dacă nu, o
să mă mut lângă sile pentru că locul lui
sile
are și o ciată pe adâncime și el
pescuiește cumva în fața ei, iar eu aș
vrea să mă duc să pescuiesc după ea.
Deci, dacă n am nicio trăsătură aici în
trei patu ore, o să mă duc să pescuiesc
lângă el și să vedem ce este și acolo.
Cumva asta este ziua în care mă plimb,
în care caut peștele.
Dacă ieri am început să risc și am
plecat de pe locul de pescuit în jurul
orei 2:00 2:30 să caut peștele cumva și
astăzi am zis că voi face la fel, dar
na, nu se știe, efectiv nu știu.
Oarecum sunt ori sunt mulțumit pentru
partida pe care am avut o până acum. Am
prins pește, am prins și un pește mare
și acum parcă așa îmi doresc să prind
pește mare, deși pentru cameră este mult
mai frumos să ai activitate, să ai mai
multe drilluri, dar parcă îmi doresc
peștele mare și cumva dau pe stau pe
adâncime pentru că, na, vreau să vreau
să prind un pește mai mare. Poate chiar
mai mare de 11, dar na, vom vedea dacă
dacă se nimerește. Dacă nu, sunt buni și
ăia de cinci, de șase, de te [râsete]
oricum, vedem ce se întâmplă. Să vă fac
un mic update. S a făcut ora 3:00. Nu am
avut absolut nicio trăsătură. M am
uitat, m am mutat de pe locul pe care am
fost dimineață. Am venit lângă Sile,
Sile. A avut astăzi câțiva pești, a luat
câțiva crapi între 3 și 5 kg. Mihai la
fel, a luat și el doi de patru. Băieții
care au pescuit ieri pe întinsură pe apă
de 2 m și au avut rezultate bune, astăzi
n au făcut nimic și au venit și ei aici
după noi. S au pus vizavi și în 10
minute au luat și ei doi pești. Se pare
că eu nu am luat nimic. Între timp m a
luat și răceala.
Sunt înfundat, mă doare capul, nu prea
am chef de nimic, dar nu mă las. Mai
sunt încă două ore de pescuit. Sper eu
să schimb să schimb partida. Am rămas în
continuare pe bile de 24 și de 20. Am
băgat și una pe momitor cu pelete de 15,
dar nu este problemă de hrănire pentru
că ceilalți au prins. Au prins, cel
puțin Sile prinde la două bile de 24. El
așa pescuiește, pescuiește doar după
pește mare. Ă, deci nu este problemă de
hrănire că se hrănește apatic, ci este
problemă că nu se hrănește suficient de
mult încât să vină pe patul de nadă să
ia mai multe bile, să în așa fel încât
să găsească și bilele noastre, să avem
să avem mai multe trăsături sau cel
puțin eu. Am făcut o nădire
corespunzătoare. Am nădit în larg. Am
nădit cu praștia. Am dat suficiente bile
încât să strâng peștele, dar se pare că
încă nu a răspuns. Sau a răspuns la
patul de nadă. El a venit, a mâncat pe
patul de nadă, dar prin ghinion nu a
nimerit să ia una din bilele mele pe
care le am la cârlig. Asta este. Ăsta
este pescuitul. Mai așteptăm încă două
ore. Dacă nu mergem la dacă nu mai prind
nimic. Oricum merg la cazare
și mai am și mâine o partidă de
hai să zic cred că de la 7:00 până la
12.
Am o trăsătură pe lanseta a doua. Este
pe adâncime. Nu știu ce e. Sper să nu
fie pește mic.
O tot
bingăne
fiind prima trăsătură de astăzi. Ia, ia,
ia. Hai, ha hai pleacă cu ea. Hai să
vedem.
Poate e vreunul de 15 kg care stă așa cu
ea în gură. Știți ce zic? Se joacă un
pic cu ea și la un moment dat pleacă pe
ran.
Vă dați seama, prima tastătură de de
astăzi e
Oare ar fi trebuit să l iau din
țăcăneală? Să încerc când pot țăcănea să
l să l înțep? Nu știu.
Eu am sperat că intră pe rar. Voi ce
părere aveți? Scrieți mi în comentarii
dacă ar fi trebuit să l iau din
țăcăneală când țăcănea să încerc să l
înțep sau am procedat corect că am
așteptat să plece pe run.
Deci fii atent că de cinci minute o
zăpăcește și acuma. Bă, hai mă, hai mă,
du te pe ran mă. Ia uite. Bă, nu mi vine
să cred, mă.
>> Păi, stai să ți povestesc ce a pățit
Eugen mai devreme.
>> Ia, ia, ia. Ai să mi bag piciorul.
>> Ia l din țecăneală. Ia din țecăneală că
a luat Eugen. A avut o namilă de n a
reușit să țină de el cu epica extreme.
>> Vorbesc serios.
>> Uite și la mine.
>> Hai, hai, hai, hai, că eu dau din
țăcăneală. Ia dacă tu zici. Deci, dragi
pescari dacă l pierd este vina lui Mihai
Manea. Da, cu el vorbesc la telefon.
Acuma acuma eu dau. Ia,
>> ia să vedem. Mihăiță.
Da.
Nu e, mă, Mihăiță.
O avea în gură. Am simțit o cum i am
scos o din gură.
Băga mi aș picioarele să mi bag
prima trăsătură, dragi pescari, de azi.
Prima.
Hai, de capul meu.
Neața, dragi pescari. Suntem în a patra
zi de pescuit. Am ajuns pe locul de
pescuit și am dat am reușit să lansez o
lansetă și am zis să dau drumul la
cameră
pentru că
așa ceva nu am mai văzut în viața mea în
Delta Dunării să sare peștele. Cum sare
acum? Deci, efectiv peste tot sunt
sărituri de pești. Nu sar efectiv în
sus, ci doar la suprafață un pic dau cu
coada sau cu aripioarele dorsale.
Sincer să fiu cu voi, nu știu dacă sunt
crapi sau sângeri. Pe sonar arată mult
pește aici. Este un alt loc, tot pe
sulina
tot de la Mila 8 în jos.
Și am dat cu sonarul. Am văzut că este
foarte mult pește și ca drept dovadă
sare peste tot. Deci efectiv peste tot
sare. Se aud Se aud valuri peste tot. O
să dați camera pornită, poate o să
vedeți și voi pe voi pe aici prin jurul
bărcii câteva câteva sărituri. Între
timp o să mi pregătesc lansetele. Cele
trei lansete
trei dintre lansete le am lăsat
eu le am lăsat în barcă pe ponton cu
boilis la cârli. Na, nu scot boilessul
și dimineață. Acum când am ajuns, am
constatat că trei dintre ele aveau firul
de păr tăiat, probabil de la șoareci,
șobolani care vin de pe mal și se
hrănesc cu ce lăsăm prin barcă. Așa că
vă zic și vouă să aveți grijă când
lăsați lucrurile în barcă sau când
plecați. Să nu lăsați boilessuri cel
puțin dacă nu sunt acoperite, dacă nu
sunt băgate în niște găleți pentru că o
să pățiți, o să pățiți ce am pățit eu.
La mine este foarte ușor, dar alții au
pățit și mai nasoale. Dacă îți intră în
barcă începi să ți mănânce firele. Dacă
au hrană acolo, practic își fac culcu și
încep să rudă tot. Bun. Deci se aude
peste tot în zona aceea. Au fost trei
sărituri. Sper că le auziți și voi pe
cameră sau sper să le vedeți. O să las
camera pornită cât îmi pregătesc eu
lansetele
și sper astăzi să am activitate. Sper să
scot câțiva pești. Aseară am încheiat cu
zero pești. Ieri nu am prins absolut
niciun pește. O singură trăsătură am
avut. Am crezut că este trăsătură de
pește mare pentru că a început s o s o
țăcăne un pic și din experiența de la
peștele peștii anteriori care i am
prins, cel puțin în partida asta am
văzut că bingăne un pic, după care se
lasă pe ea și pleacă și na, asta am
crezut și ieri, dar de fapt n a fost
așa. Am încercat să l înțep din
ciupituri și nu am reușit și aia a fost
singura mea șansă de a prinde pește.
Bun, mă apuc de treabă și să vedem ce
facem astăzi.
Am mai prezentat și în alte clipuri
cireașa de pe tort. Vă mai prezint o
dată. Aici am paleta de 15 mm Secret
Aroma pusă pe momitor, nadă pe momitor.
Iar în nada de pe momitor am adăugat și
pelete de 5 mm fish meal.
Nada este făcută deja de trei zile și
încă este ok. Nu am mai făcut altă pungă
de nadă ieri și alaltă ier nu am mai dat
la momitor, dar acuma o să încerc din
nou să dau la momitor pentru că ieri na
n am avut rezultate doar pe bilă. Și
astăzi încerc și la momor să vedem care
e treaba. Deci, uitați cum arată bilă.
Da,
după
de ieri, nu știu cât a stat ieri în apă
și tot pe asta o s o arunc
până când o fac și pe cealaltă.
>> [muzică]
[muzică]
>> peste
ceva se întâmplă de Să
deci peștele ăsta care a fost acum a
plecat pe ran. Ă trebuia să se agațe.
Adică na, fiind pe ran, simt efectiv cum
îi scot cum îi scot cârligul din gâră.
Am verificat cârligul să văd dacă este
dacă înțeapă. Înțeapă foarte bine.
Montura arată ok.
Singurul Singurul gând unde mă duce
treaba asta
ar fi că este sânge. Având gura mare nu
reușește să se înțepe și din câte știu
este și osoasă gura sângelui. Sper să nu
zic o prostie, dar
poate reușesc să scot unul dacă mai am o
trăsătură și atunci o să mi dau seama
dacă e ce fel de pește este. E aproape
imposibil de trei ori de trei ori să i
scoți să i scoți cârligul din gură.
Deci aici
aici am Secret aroma de 15 mm peletă,
gama cireașa de pe tort. Aici am 10 mm
căpșună,
tot gama cireașă de pe tort. Aici am 20
mm semisolubil delta activ. Și aici tot
20 mm semisolubil Delta Activ. Da, bila
este lăsată de ieri, deci este de ieri
acolo. Ați văzut? Am arătat o mai
devreme. S a făcut S a făcut micuță și
iar am trăsătură aici. Eu cred că e
pește mic totuși,
dar atunci când l am înțepat, adică l am
simțit pește mare, cel puțin la ultima
la ultima trăsătură, dacă nu știu dacă
se vede pe cameră, dar firul o luase în
partea stângă, adică cumva urca cu ea în
amonte.
Deci, dragi pescari, am avut primul
prima trăsătură pe planeta de 10 mm.
Este un ciortănaș,
dar asta înseamnă că este și crab aici
și este posibil să fie și mai mare.
Ia,
uitați aici, dragi pescari, este prima
captură pe ziua de astăzi. Un ciortănaș
la câteva sute de game. Îl eliberăm
imediat
și sperăm să vină alții mai mari.
Nada este pregătită deja de trei zile și
bineînțeles că peletele s au topit.
Mă rog, s au umflat, s au topit pentru
că așa se întâmplă cu ele. Și o să i mai
adaug acuma niște pelete și o să
amestec. N o să fac altă altă nadă. Nu,
acuma pe asta n are sens să fac alta.
Avem aici paletă Fishmeal
cu concentrație 32% proteină care sunt
fabricate la noi în România și eu le
folosesc cu cu nada de sălbatic.
Ia am o altă trăsătură.
Hai să vedem dacă o ia.
Să mă dau un pic din fața camerei să mă
așez jos să văd ce trăsătura.
Cam așa trebuie să arate o nadă de
sălbatic. Hai să încerc să mă pun în
lateral. Deci cam așa trebuie să arate o
nadă de sălbatic cu multe particule mari
care să se desfacă, să rămână pe
substrat și în același timp și
ingrediente solubile care să facă un nor
să se ducă în curent și să atragă
peștele. Uitați, avem aici o altă
trăsătură,
dar peștele este abatic, nu o ia, deci
nu se hrănește bine. Da.
Sper că vedeți pe cameră
particulele mari și peletele.
Mhm.
Hai
operan.
Frumos, frumos. Bine,
deci începem să avem activitate, dragi
pescari.
Ăsta pare un pic mai un pic mai măricel.
O să l vedem imediat.
Aici am bilă Delta Activ de 20 mm, doar
ce am schimbat o și am băgat una
solubilă ca să se activeze mai repede.
Deși ei se hrănesc apatic, atunci când
sunt înțepați au suficientă putere.
Uitați cum face bățul. Și este un băț cu
acțiune de 400 de g. Da. Ia uitați vă.
Și sunt sigur că n are mai mult de 1 kg
jumătate, două. Hai să vedem.
Uitați vă și voi.
da
Deci
am avut doi pești,
doi pești în 40 de minute cred când a de
când am ajuns. Ceea ce este bine
înseamnă că peștele este aici, nu se
hrănește cum ar trebui să hrănească. Ați
văzut ce trăsături finuțe și la pelete
la fel. Cred eu că voi face mai multe că
voi avea mai multe drilluri la pelete,
dar trebuie schimbate mereu. Trebuie
schimbate mereu Hai să l scot pe ăsta.
Când pescuim pe apă mică cu momitoare și
cu pelete mici de 10, mai intră și
roșioare, mai intră și carași, dar avem
șanse să ne intre și crap.
De 30 de minute n am mai avut nicio
ciupitură de crab.
Am avut două roșioare.
Nu știu dacă s a mutat. Sper că nu s a
mutat. Oricum voi rămâne pe locul ăsta
până plec. La 11:00 vreau să ies de pe
apă. De fapt, să ies de pe apă, să plec
de pe locul de pescuit și voi rămâne
aici. Chiar dacă s a mutat, chiar dacă
nu s a mutat, voi rămâne aici. Oricum i
am dat bile, i am făcut o nădire.
Dacă intră pe bile o să găsească și bila
mea. O să stea pe patul de nadă. Dacă nu
intră și cam mutat din anumite motive
care nu țin de noi, nu țin de nadă, nu
țin de momeală, nu țin de noi ca
pescari, nu avem ce face. Dar oricum o
să vedem
să vă arăt cât de frumos s a activat
bila. Da, bila delta activ.
Uitați vă și voi.
Bine, este de schimbat. Acum o s o
schimb.
N ai cum să i reziști. Deci n ai cum
dacă ești pește, n ai cum să i reziști.
Și a mai venit un ciortănaș.
Ăsta a venit aproape de mal. În partea
dreaptă am o
Hopa! În partea dreaptă am o cioată și
am dat aproape de mal.
Ia să vedem
peleta de
15 mm,
unada pentru sălbatic și peletele de
15 mm.
Ăsta
>> [muzică]
[muzică]
>> Dacă asta avem pe vad, asta prindem. Ce
să le facem? Noroc că am fost inspirat
să bag și momitoare pentru că avem un
pic de activitate la ciortan. Atunci
când peștele mai mare, nu vrea să se
hrănească, nu trage, băgăm momitoare și
avem șanse să prindem. Eu de multe ori
am schimbat partida băgând momitoare și
prinzând pești mai mari decât acesta.
Da, asta avem acuma în față, asta
prindem.
Un lucru pe care l am observat acum,
peștii sunt poate foarte apatici și se
hrănească
foarte greu. Am mai pățit asta în
primăvară în care stăteam câte 10 minute
pe trăsătură.
Efectiv stăteau cu peleta și nu luau
cârligul. Adică trăgeau, se vedeau mici,
mici trăsături pe vârf, dar nu, nu luau
peleta, nu intrau pe run. Ce o să fac
acum? Am avut am două lansete pe pe
momitoare și pe lede și la una am avut
cârlig de 10, la una cârlig de cârlig de
10, la una cârlig de opt, la cea cârlig
de 10 am avut peletă de 10, la cealaltă
am avut peletă de 15 și acuma o să
schimb, o să pun cârlig de 10 și la cea
unde aveam cârlig de opt, ca să ne mai
distrăm un pic la cortan, să vedem dacă
mai intră ceva. Iar celelalte două din
stânga în continuare le las pe bilet de
20. Poate intre și ceva mai mare. Uitați
cât de bine cât de bine arată n pe
momitor.
Nu știu cât a trecut cât de când am
lansat o și am avut trăsătura cred că
aproximativ 20 de minute
și încă a rămas. Și stai cât de frumos
se văd și peletele.
Ohoh!
Deci ăsta a venit de lângă cioa
dreaptă la câțiva metri de mal.
Tot la monitor. Peletă de 10 mm, cârn de
10.
Hai să l și vedem.
Frumos.
la motor, mă. Uitați vă câtă putere are.
Nu s a terminat drill ul, mă băiești.
Voi ce credeați?
Așa frumos.
Facem din nou o lansare. Așa arată
prezentarea pe substrat. N am mai
schimbat peleta pentru că doar ce am
schimbat o
și poate mai intră unul.
Când voi scoate și lanseta a doua,
când voi scoate și lanseta a doua, cea
care este tot pe momitor, o s o dau tot
în partea dreaptă aproape de de cioata
pe care pe care o am acolo în apă pentru
că am văzut că au venit două trăsături
una după alta de acolo și e posibil ca
peștele să fie mutat la ceapă, dar
vedem. E posibil să se plimbe. Da, până
atunci s ar putea să mai am o trăsătură
la cea din dreapta.
Ați văzut ranul? A cugulit o un pic, un
pic, a luat o, a plecat cu ea și i a dat
drumul.
Aici am bilet de 20.
Aici mă aștept să intre ceva mai mare.
Acum voi schimba bilele la cele din
stânga și cred că este ultima lansare la
ele. Dacă n o să am trăsătură. Asta
este. Una o s o dau tot așa un pic mai
pe adâncime. Asta unde am avut și runul
de mai devreme
și cam o oră mai stau, după care strâng
și plec. O iau spre cazare, îmi iau
bagajele și o iau spre Tulcea.
Să vă mai zic ceva despre năditul pe
Sulina.
Lucrul ăsta l am descoperit într o
partidă în care pescuiam la mal, aproape
de mal, pe apă de 3 m și a trecut un
vapor cum a trecut cel care l ați văzut
mai devreme. Stând eu ancorat, eram
ancorat în curent, la un moment dat am
început să aud ceva în barcă, ceva se
lovea de barcă și zic, mă, ce se
întâmplă? Când mă uit, practic pietrele
și nisipul se ridicau de la fund,
pietricele micuțe se ridicau de la fund
și loveau în barcă. Când trecem un
astfel de de vapor, gândiți vă ce se
întâmplă pe sub apă. Și ce voiam să vă
zic în legătură cu năditul. Venim pe
locul de pescuit, nădim. Noi zicem că am
nădit bine, trecem un vapor de ăsta, ce
credeți că se întâmplă cu bilele
noastre? Le ridică pe toate și le duce
la vale. Da. Eu după fiecare vapor care
trece, mai arunc bile, fac din nou
nădire pentru că vreau să mă asigur că
pe substrat am bile cel puțin pe zona
unde pescuiesc. Ok? Vă recomand să
faceți și voi asta. [muzică]
[muzică]
Gata, dragi pescari, partida mea de
pescuit este gata. Mai stau cinci
minute, strâng lansetele și o iau spre
cazare. A fost o partidă cu de toate. A
fost o partidă cu căldură în care a
trebuit să stau la tricou și la
pantaloni scurți. Astăzi am stat
îmbrăcat. Miercuri când am ajuns am stat
îmbrăcat.
Între timp au luat și răceala. Am venit
eu un pic răcit, dar acum s a s a
agravat de ieri s a agravat.
Sunt așa un pic cheaun. Nu prea am chef.
Pește s a prins. Am prins în toate
zilele, în afară de ieri, dar s a prins
și ieri pește. Pe cei care au fost cu
noi au prins pește. Eugen cu Dorel au
prins pește. Ei au avut cea mai mare
activitate de altfel. Dar nu au prins
pește mare. Maxim a fost cred că la 4 5
kg.
Mihai a prins și el pește. A prins și de
7 kg. Astăzi a luat unul de 7 sau 8 kg,
nu l a cântărit și a mai luat câțiva
câțiva pești la 2 3 kg.
Eu astăzi am avut activitate la Ciortan
și vedeta partidei a fost crapul de 11
kg. pe care l ați văzut mai devreme. Cam
asta a fost partida. Ați văzut, am
pescuit cu toate produsele GTA Fishing,
am pescuit și la momitoare, am pescuit
și cu bilele, noile bile Delta Active.
În momentul în care eu filmez acum,
bilele nu sunt pe piață. Deja au fost
testate de mulți pescari. Noi le testăm
și pescuim cu ele de mult. O să le
lansăm, dar nu știu să vă spun exact
când pentru că deja avem comenzi în
avans. Primul lot pe care l am făcut l
am dat la cunoștințe pentru că zis ră și
noi bilele astea. Al doilea lot la fel
se va da este gata când ajung la
București și se vor da se vor da și
acestea și nu știu exact când când le
vom da drumul pe pe site. Toate
produsele le găsiți pe gdafishing.ro, O,
inclusiv mixul de pelete de 5 pe care l
am tot promovat eu. Este un produs nou
în site ul nostru. Nu este un produs
nou. Noi l am îl avem de ceva timp, dar
până acum nu l am scos la vânzare și
acuma îl avem și la vânzare. Bun, cam
asta a fost. Pescuit pe brațul
octombrie la sfârșit, începând de
noiembrie. Vremea a fost foarte
schimbătoare.
Când a fost cald, când a fost frig. Cota
este mică, presiunea atmosferică a fost
când în scădere, când în creștere. Deci
nu a fost o
linie, nu a fost o un echilibru. Și asta
s a văzut și în comportamentul peștelui,
deși am văzut mulți pești pe sonar, i am
localizat, să zic așa. Trăsăturile nu au
fost, frecvența trăsăturilor nu a fost
foarte mare, dar în orice caz pentru
luna noiembrie, început de noiembrie
este foarte foarte foarte bun. Cam atât.
Nu uitați să lăsați un comentariu dacă
aveți o întrebare. Nu uitați să lăsați
un like, un share și ne vedem data
viitoare.